as the left continues its organized
assault on Elon Musk and X the owner of
the only non- leftist social media
platform has a three-word message for
those who would censor him there's a
public perception that that was part of
a apology tour if you will that this had
been said online there was all of the
criticism there was advertisers leaving
we talked to Bob Iger stop you hope uh
don't advertise you don't want them to
advertise no what do you mean
if somebody's going to try to Blackmail
me with advertising blackmail me with
money go
yourself
but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey Bob here in the
audience well well let me ask you
then that's how I feel don't
advertise in case there's any confusion
the guy has no idea what to say and Elon
is absolutely right if the richest man
in the world is not allowed to speak his
mind if the richest man in the world is
not even allowed to let other people
speak the truth as we see it then why
even go on pretending that we live in
anything resembling a free country
anymore I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael NS
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers head on
over to good ranchers.com to find all of
your gifts this year use code NES kwes
to save a bonus of 10% off today on top
of their December sale great great tunur
has switched her activis M away from
defending the sun monster and and saving
the Earth toward crushing Zionism in her
words we will get to that in just one
moment first though I don't want to move
off Twitter too quickly because while
Elon Musk is resisting the private
sector attempts to censor him through
advertising boycotts to get him to fall
in line and stop speaking his mind at at
the same time Elon is fighting public
sector attempts to intimidate his user
as well all for the same purpose and
that is coming from Jack Smith Jack
Smith is this lawyer who is special
counsel investigating Donald Trump for I
don't know putting too much katchup on
his hamburger or something whatever the
latest doj attempt to put Donald Trump
in prison is and as part of that
investigation Jack Smith is demanding
information on every single Twitter user
who has ever in any way interacted with
Donald Trump's Twitter account
which is to
say every Twitter user is there is there
any account on Twitter that has not
interacted with Trump on Twitter at some
point I'm not just talking about a
private message I'm not even just
talking about a public message I'm
talking about anyone who's ever liked
retweeted in any way interacted with his
account we're talking about millions and
millions of accounts we know this now
because we've seen the heavily redact
search warrant and that heavily redacted
search warrant includes all Associated
accounts the names of those accounts as
well as logs and metadata pertaining to
those
accounts this is maybe the most
expansive information grab from the doj
ever and and what is the purpose of this
it's clear enough to me the purpose of
this request is one to figure out who
the political enemies are who the
enemies of Joe Biden are but two it's to
intimidate Americans the very fact that
the doj is making this request is going
to intimidate people it's going to tell
people goodness I better stop
interacting with these Republican
accounts I better stop amplifying them I
better stop responding to them I better
stop quote tweeting them I better censor
myself and and this is one of the great
tools of leftwing censorship I talked to
a couple guys uh yesterday who were
swinging by the office and I I was
speaking in a politically incorrect way
and I I said something I felt totally
anod but the guy said hey you can't say
that so what do you mean I can't say
that they said well you what you said is
very offensive I said I don't think it
is they said oh no it is you're not
allowed to say that anymore I said well
did I offend you they said well no you
didn't offend me I said do can you point
to anyone that I did offend any real
person they said no said so what's the
big deal they said well no in theory
there's a hypothetical person and so you
got to you got to refrain from saying
that and this is how the left Works yes
there is the overt censorship yes
YouTube will take down an episode if you
say something that's too politically
incorrect if you contradict the woke
agenda yes it's true that Facebook will
pull advertising or something if you
contradict the woke agenda but that's
only a minor part of the censorship plan
the bigger part is when they intimidate
you and harass you and make your life
much more difficult
when you contradict them so that you
censor
yourself you don't refer to a man who
identifies as a woman as he you just you
just don't maybe you don't use any
pronouns at all you just don't want to
talk about it maybe you don't raise
questions about the efficacy of the
covid vaccine the fouchy ouchy maybe you
don't raise questions about the
legitimacy of the 2020 election because
you just don't want to hear it and you
don't want to come under the magnifying
glass of the doj which now now is is not
so much investigating with a magnifying
glass as with a gigantic fishing net to
take all of those data in and look at
all of us this is not just happening in
America in Ireland it's it's even sadder
so this is being reported by the BBC
right now there was a little bit of
graffiti written on a wall in Ireland
says Irish lives
matter no I don't like graffiti I like
that statement though I think Irish
lives do matter and according to the
BBC this is anti-immigration signage
here's how the BBC is reporting it
graffiti reading Irish lives matter was
dobbed on the wall of the Kennedy Center
on the Falls Road overnight people
before prophets Jerry Carroll said there
was quote no place in our society for
this kind of racist poison racist poison
to say that the people of your country
matter in any way racist poison sin Fain
MP Paul masi described the signs as
disgraceful adding that they had been
erected in an attempt to create fear and
intimidate people disgraceful to say
that the people of your own country
matter in any way it's to intimidate
people yeah what no you know what's to
intimidate people that news report
that's to intimidate the Irish from in
any way standing up for themselves and
their culture and their history and
their own interests and their own
self-government if it is a hate
crime to write a little bit of graffiti
that says the people of our country
matter then what that means is your
country is no longer governed by or for
the people of your country Ireland is no
longer governed by or for the
Irish the Irish have had a difficult
history the Irish have not always had
the best political luck John lenon had a
a song which was if you had the Luck of
the Irish you'd be sorry and wish you
was dead if you had the Luck of the
Irish you'd wish you were English
instead well it looks like their
political situation has not improved at
all now of course some of the MPS some
of these politicians look Irish they've
got Irish names they've got lilting
Irish
accents but they're not really Irish
they're not governing in the interests
of Ireland they're governing in the
interests of some Far distant imperial
capital they're governing in the
interest of Brussels for instance
they're governing as satraps for some
Imperial power a liberal Imperial power
that does not have the interests of the
nation first this is why you're seeing a
surge of nationalism perhaps not in
Ireland certainly not among the
political class I guess among the people
you see a little bit that's why they're
spraying the graffiti but it's why
you're seeing a surge of nationalism in
Britain through the brexit in Italy
through the Malon election in Sweden uh
in the Netherlands in the United States
all over the place
why
because we are being told all over the
West that our nations are not only
unimportant but evil wrong to to have
any care for your own country and its
history and its people is
disgraceful and and totally unacceptable
and people don't want to hear that so so
you're now seeing an opposition not so
much between the left and the right as
between the people and the political
ruling class which is raising a much
deeper governing problem than the usual
battles between left and right because
it's it's raising a crisis of regime
it's it's causing people to ask hey do
we actually govern ourselves does our
government in any way have the interests
of our country first does our government
have the interests of of our country in
their minds at all and the answer that
people are increasingly coming to is no
now one interest I keep in my mind a
fair bit is the protection of the uh
defenseless among us and that's why you
got to check out pre-born right now go
to preborn docomo finally some good news
because of you our friends over at
pre-born have rescued over 44,000 babies
this year alone right now thousands of
mothers are awaiting the birth of their
precious babies and thousands upon
thousands of babies are taking their
first breath since the beginning
pre-born network of clinics has rescued
over 280,000 babies that is a miracle
and for 28 bucks you can Empower a
mother to choose Life by sponsoring her
ultrasound once she sees the precious
life that she is growing and here's her
baby's heartbeat she is twice as likely
to choose life right now through a match
your gift is doubled your generous gift
will go 100% toward life it is such an
effective way to donate to help save a
life a pre-born fundraises separately
for administrative costs so every dollar
you give is going to go towards saving
babies have your donation doubled today
by dialing pound to 250 saying keyword
baby that is pound 250 keyword baby or
donate securely at
pre-born canw that is preborn
docomo speaking of the British Isles
Megan Markle you know Megan Markle she
was the Duchess of Sussex princess Megan
sort of she married Prince Harry I've
long had a conspiracy theory that Megan
Markle is a biological weapon
constructed in America to get back at
the British crown for the War of 1812 we
built her here we assembled her
perfectly to just go over to England and
completely destroy the royal family and
the monarchy she's doing a pretty good
job at it well Megan Markle and her
husband Prince Harry they've come over
here to America it's a little bit like a
boomerang unfortunately the weapon has
come back on us and reportedly Megan
Mara said she never wants to set foot in
England again which is a little awkward
because her father-in-law is the king of
England
the only reason I care about this story
is not because I I do sort of like the
Royals I'm a little bit anglophilic but
they they can sort out their own
politics the the reason that I care
about this story is what it tells you
about marriage the the state of modern
marriage not just among Aristocrats and
nobility and royalty overseas but among
everyone right here which
is did she not think of this issue
before she married the prince did did
she not consider whether or not she
wanted to steep foot in England before
she married uh the second most notable
prince of
England you would think that's the sort
of thing you would consider did she not
recognize that when she married a member
of the royal family a senior member of
the royal family that she might have
some duties and responsibilities that go
along with
that and then the moment that she
encountered those responsibilities she
said oh no I want to go play pretend I
don't want to actually be a princess I
just want to go play a princess in
Disney movies I don't want to be the
real thing I just want to play pretend
and then go off to my Malibu mansion
monteo mansion and I don't know Sip shab
and not have any
responsibilities you don't have to agree
on
everything be before you head into a
marriage with somebody but you do have
to agree on what a marriage is I get
asked for marriage advice all the time
from young
people because marriage is unusual these
days because people are delaying getting
married because our stupid culture tells
people don't get married put your career
first put yourself first don't think
about another person don't have children
for goodness sakes children are a
sexually transmitted disease you need to
use contraception you need to have
abortions you need to put that off and
freeze your eggs and maybe have a kid
when you're 50 and and this is not
conducive to people's happiness and so
there's a crisis of marriage a crisis of
marriage because the Supreme Court
redefined what marriage is in an absurd
way so we can't even answer that
question but that is that is the
fundamental question of political
Society
what are we all doing together what are
we aiming at what do we think is good
what are we pursuing here together and
at what level there's the national level
of government there's the state level of
government there's the community level
of government and then there's the basic
political unit which is the family which
is a marriage and when you get
married I don't think you need to have
some clinical job interview kind of
procedure I don't think you need to sit
across from your prospective wife and
have a 10 bullet point checklist and
okay well you you check off seven of the
10 so I guess that's a passing grade you
only get a c but you know okay close
enough maybe we'll get married no you
know that's not the most romantic thing
I ever heard you don't need to agree on
every single thing at least not when you
first get married because by the way
over the course of marriage you will
grow together or you can grow apart but
but if you have a real proper
functioning marriage and you're spending
time together and you're deferring to
one another in their respective Realms
and you throw feminism out the window
then you're going to grow together most
likely that's the question you have to
answer not uh what are we going to have
for dinner not whose house are we going
to go to for Christmas not even what
school are we going to send the kids to
you have to ask what is marriage that
should be the next daily wire
documentary we had the smash it what is
a woman now we need something just as
basic which is what is
marriage and today most people don't
know for Megan Markle marriage
means live out of fantasy from a Disney
movie have a little arm candy Prince to
to accompany your handbag and your high
heels Prince Harry probably had a
different understanding of
marriage the more traditional people
have a different understanding of
marriage than that and it creates a big
big problem if you guys don't agree on
that when you are going in now speaking
of foreigners there's an unusual
unexpected story out of Argentina The
Eccentric uh new president-elect of
Argentina Javier mle
radical
libertarian populist candidate who won
unexpectedly according to the experts in
Argentina he's considering converting to
Judaism this is according to Bloomberg
News why is he converting to Judaism I
don't I don't know for certain it's
unusual to convert to Judaism Judaism is
not a prelati religion in fact it's very
very difficult you have to go through an
extensive process and try multiple times
and but here's one potential explanation
mle who has all sorts of eccentric views
on tantric sex and all kinds of uh
unusual spiritual and even sexual topics
he said the truth is I did not get to
know the rebi personally a major figure
in habad labure Judaism but just in the
last year I had the privilege of
visiting the Reb's grave twice there I
asked for his holy blessing to be
elected president of Argentina and this
blessing became a reality this week so
some are saying well he's just this C
Mystic who thinks that because he
visited a grave and said I want to be
president of Argentina and he got it he
he now credits the rebi of of Judaism
with uh giving it to him and so he's
going to convert to Judaism out of
gratitude for that I think there's a
much simpler explanation here as to why
mle would be interested in converting to
Judaism the answer is because he's a
radical
libertarian and as
such mle feels uncomfortable with the
religion in which he was raised and
that's
Catholicism there are plenty of
Libertarians who are just fine in the
Catholic Church there there's the Acton
Institute in fact we've we've uh
interviewed father suro who runs the
Acton Institute on here there there are
Libertarians among the Catholics but
Catholic Social teaching does not
totally Accord with libertarianism
libertarianism is a modern movement
liberalism is a modern movement and
Catholicism is not modern whatever you
want to call Catholicism it ain't
modern now Judaism obviously is not
modern either but Judaism better
accommodates itself to some of those
modern movements I was talking to a
friend of mine one time I said why is
there so much anti-Semitism why do
people hate the Jews so much and he said
one Theory I've got as to why people
hate the Jews so much is that the Jews
uniquely have been able to thrive in
modernity while still maintaining their
culture and their traditions and their
Heritage and no other group has really
been able to do that it's usually one or
the other either you thrive in our
modern material society and and give up
your whole culture become totally
deracinated or you go off into the woods
and you you know you become Amish or
something but you you get to maintain
your culture but you're not particularly
financially successful and the Jews
perhaps uniquely have been able to to do
both at the same time uh Catholic Social
teaching says that one can't just be a
radical libertarian one doesn't want to
eradicate the state one doesn't want to
just completely dismiss any kind of
social welfare program out of hand and
Malay hates that he's he's accused the
the pope of all sorts of terrible things
and the Church of all sorts of terrible
things and I know a lot of people aren't
thrilled with the Pope and he's said
certainly um
he's made questionable declarations
about politics but I think this goes to
a deeper philosophical issue which is if
one is a true perfectly doctrinaire
radical
libertarian then the traditional
teachings of Christendom with regard to
political economy don't quite work and
it reveals that that libertarianism
while it there's much to recommend it on
the
right also is kind of a leftwing move
movement it doesn't fit exactly on the
left right political Spectrum now
speaking of the Jews grunberg wants to
crush them we'll get to that in one
second first though I want to help your
dog which is why you got to check out
Ruff greens right now go to Ruff
greens.com the holidays are here while
you at shopping for your kids family and
friends do not forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with Ruff
greens naturopathic doctor Dennis black
the founder of Ruff greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food might as well be
considered dead food since it contains
very little nutrition let Ru greens
bring your dogs food back to life Ru
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough Greens on their
food every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about sorry excuse me are raving
about rough greens it supports healthy
joints improves bad breath boosts energy
levels and so much more we are what we
eat that goes for dogs too naturopathic
doctor Dennis black is so confident that
Ruff greens will improve your dog's
health he's offering a free jump start
trial bag delivered to your door in just
a few business days go to Ru greens.com
or call 844 ruff1 123 that is Ruf
greens.com melm AEL or call 844 Ru
f123 today lady Ballers the most
triggering comedy of the decade is
streaming exclusively on dailywire plus
tomorrow night at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern you've heard us talking about
this movie all week now I get to tell
you even more because I was at the daily
wire red carpet review with all the
other
stars of our very first F length feature
comedy last night the movie is excellent
there were a lot a lot of friends came
in for it I was sitting in the movie
theater for the premiere uh next to
sweet little Alisa on one side of me and
senator Ted Cruz on the other side of
me only one of whom is is a star of the
movie uh we had a lot of other friends
fly in from all over the country the
performers in the movie and we didn't
know what to make of it none of us had
seen the movie beforehand I had modest
expectations I knew the script was very
very good I didn't know if they would
pull it off I was only on set for a
couple of
days the movie is terrific it's
terrific Jeremy is a genius I don't
don't tell him I said it it's excellent
this is the movie that Hollywood should
have been racing to make but they did
not they would not so we did it lady
Ballers Premier is tomorrow night
exclusively on daily wi Plus at 8m
Eastern greata wants to crush the Jews
uh here is greata thunberg in Stockholm
uh shaking up her usual climate activism
doing a rain dance and screaming at the
sun monster to uh do some other kind of
dance and scream at the hebraic
[Applause]
people so I I can't quite make out
Swedish either but apparently the chant
there is
cman which means uhis yeah which means
Crush Zionism this was at a prop
Palestine rally
which leads me back to one of the only
points I've made as this war broke out
because there are high passions about
this war in the Middle East some people
have a strong connection to Israel some
people have family members in Israel for
instance some people have spent a lot of
time there some people uh believe in the
theological premises of Zionism this
includes Jews this even includes certain
Evangelical Christians uh some people on
the flip side have strong affinities for
the Palestine Liberation cause mostly on
the left but a little bit on the right
and
I'm I'm not all that interested in those
nuances of the conflict I want to
protect innocent people I want to avoid
World War II but that that's about where
my interest ends in that there are a lot
of conflicts all around the world I I
have an interest in the negoro carabat
conflict between Armenia and aeran we
have an interest in the Ukraine Russia
conflict also because we don't want to
go into World War II but there are a lot
of different conflicts how does one make
any sense of the Israel Palestine
conflict which has G on for a long time
in its present form for 100 years and in
some form or rather for centuries and
Millennia even and the answer is my
little rule of thumb
is if greata thunberg is on one side of
an issue I'm probably on the other side
just as a rule of thumb okay if gunur
hates something then that's probably a
pretty good recommendation of
it one of the arguments I've heard from
people uh trying to take a more Pro
Palestine side here is not the great a
thunbergs not the ilhan Omar is not the
Rashida Talib but but sane normal people
is they say well I just don't agree with
the way in which the Israeli state was
established because the Israeli State
the modern Israeli state was
established as a consequence of the
balfor dec a in 1917 which is a way for
the British Empire to Curry favor and
win some support from Jews around the
world and to support the political
project of Zionism which had predated it
by some decades and then after World War
II because of the atrocities that
happened to the Jews uh as a result of
Nazi Germany then there was even more
political impetus for the official
founding of the state of Israel in 1948
and it received a un Charter and uh you
know but as a result of that it
displaced a lot of people and it created
a new entity on the map and no no one
had any right to do that and that's just
a kind of imperialism and I've heard all
of the arguments I totally agree I
totally agree that it's a complicated
issue sorry I don't agree with all of
the arguments that people make but I
certainly agree it's a complicated
issue but what are you going to do now
even if you think that the establishment
of the modern state of Israel was
questionable it was established what are
you going to do what what une Earth are
you supposed to do what is grun BG's
answer here what is Rashida talib's
answer what is ilhan Omar's answer
answer seems to me pretty clear the
answer is just wipe the place off the
map and then and then things are not
going to work out very well for the
present occupants but they don't really
have any answers just just like the libs
on on other issues don't really have any
answers they just want to tear things
down they they just want to scream and
yell and even they apply this to America
they say we need to give the Black Hills
of South Dakota back to the Lakota
Sue that's your answer we're going to
give away an area of the United States
that has four US presidents faces carved
into it Mount Rushmore we're going to
give away an area of the United States
has a quarter million Americans living
on it to who to the lotas Su we've had
the land longer than lot Su have and by
the way the lot Su stole the land from
the cheyen why don't we give it to the
Cheyenne why who did the cheyen take it
from I I discussed this topic in a
speech a couple nights ago at Vander
which you can get on the yaf YouTube
channel so I I don't just want to own
the libs here I don't just want to have
a nice piy Zinger my question is what
are you supposed to do what's your
answer these people don't have any
answer they just whine and scream and
pretend to be so much more virtuous than
the rest of us now speaking of political
polarization this story man this is this
is our this is the weird sex stuff
segment of the day and this one
man there's sex
stuff and then there's weird sex
stuff and then there is whatever the
Washington Post is writing about about
in this
article Washington Post publishing a
leather mask of a donkey with chains and
spikes and stuff and a leather mask of
an elephant and it says in the world of
sexual fetishes crossing the political
aisle is a
kink does a forced vote for The Other
Side get your pulse racing there is a
dominatrix for that and so I'm going to
cut out
some of the more lurid details here
where they talk about all sorts of
sexual objects and and fetishes they say
a fetish is is an inanimate object
technically say stiletto shoes a body
part feet for example or situation
required for sexual arousal though it's
frequently used interchangeably for the
broader term Kink which includes
pleasurable if unorthodox role playing
and you name it and these are all sorts
of fantasies well put aside those
somewhat more common fetishes and
Fantasies the new one the big one is a
political sexual
fetish guys who want their sexual
partners to make them vote for the
opposite party guys who are and this is
I assumed this was a fake thing no The
Washington Post details in in lurid
detail all these different groups online
and on various sex social media sites
thousands of people joining these groups
to say yeah I'm a liberal but I want a
republican to just call me a dumb idiot
leftist so here's just one paragraph
This is one of the more wholesome
paragraphs in an otherwise truly
degenerate article uh he said he came up
with the idea for the group after he
received messages from a handful of
users all asking for the same thing
quote I'm liberal leftist and proud but
I really want to be dominated by a
conservative nearly all of the group
members merely want to text their
fantasies to him not act them out one
man who wanted to meet up but changed
his mind described his fantasy as
wearing a trump dog collar sold on
Trump's campaign website so apparently
that's actual Trump merch and being
walked by wrri makes mites which is one
of the users I guess around Walmart to
pick out a dog bone so I'm going to
leave it there if you want to read the
rest of the article I got to hand it to
the Washington Post this is the single
most entertaining piece of Journalism I
have read in a very long time it's very
very funny it's definitely revolting but
the reason that I mention it on the show
is
because there clearly is a deeper
significance to this and and the deeper
significance is a lot of what the author
details as Kink or fetish right fetish
by the way it the the basic meaning of
that word is is an idol so you could
have a a pagan tribe that has its
fetishes disconnected largely or totally
from sex but it's just the the idols
that the people worship and so it's
applied to all these kind of weird sex
things
uh and so at that deeper level what
you're seeing is a kind of taboo what is
a taboo a taboo is a separating of
something that is that is either
extremely sacred or extremely profane or
just something you don't want to touch
it's something it's something taboo and
in our culture now the tabos are not
just some bizarre Fringe desire you ever
heard of it the taboos are political
disagreement you're not allowed to do
that anymore that's naughty it is
naughty to disagree with Joe Biden it is
naughty to have any independent
political thought it is naughty it's
shameful you got to whis SP in the back
alleys and on weird sex sites if you in
any way break from not even just the
Liberals from your political tribe it
does appear to be mostly the Liberals
here though who are signing up for this
stuff who want the conservatives to
smack them around or
something that is the sign not only of
of an unhealthy psyche that is the sign
not only of an unhealthy uh libido and
sexual desire that's the sign of an
unhealthy Society of an unhealthy
political order but of course this is
the case if you're a conservative now if
you're a prolifer the FBI might come
knocking on your door if you're lucky
they'll knock they might just kick the
door in if you're a Catholic the feds
might be shown up to your mass to spy on
your mass to try to infiltrate your
church if you're a totally peaceful
protester on January 6 the worst day in
the history of the world you could have
a US Marshal show up to your house
arrest you throw you in solitary
confinement for voicing your questions
about an obviously very dubious election
which means
that political discourse is taboo and
for some people that's
sexy for some people it's terrifying for
these guys it's probably both because
they appear to get a kick out of things
that are terrifying or disgusting or
revolting or broadly speaking taboo
yikes when political disagreement is
enough to titilate you and get your
rocks off cuz it's so naughty then our
culture is effectively no longer a free
Republic now speaking of finding
significance in otherwise shallow things
there's going to be a course taught at
Harvard on Taylor Swift
music uh Stephanie Bert I don't know
what his real name is probably Stephen
is a man who identifies
as and he's going to be teaching a
course called Taylor Swift and her
world uh the class will include some
details about Taylor Swift's current
highly publicized romance with that
football player and Professor Bert says
it's a literature course and it has a
lot of songs and songwriting it's going
to be focused on Taylor Swift's lyrics
and creative composition and how they're
connected to other page-based poets and
authors this is how you know that this
course is going to be
awful the notion that a poet needs to
have the distinction page-based added
before his
title the the other kind of poet
according to this person would be a Slam
Poet which is the absolute death of Art
and if you think that slam poetry is
anything even resembling an art form
then you certainly shouldn't be shaping
young minds but this person is says you
know William Wordsworth and Samuel
Taylor cdge who wrote some of their
poems in the Lake District which Taylor
has visited and has a song about they
look at look at all these literary
connections here oh man this is so
pathetic but this is nothing new this
sort of stuff has gone on at Elite
School for a long
time the the gut class is where every
kid in this class is going to get an A
they're not going to learn anything
they're going to they're going to listen
to some Taylor Swift music and try to
put some kind of academic patina over it
but it's going to be pretty shallow but
this has gone on for a long time because
it is still hard to get into these
schools it it is actually hard to get
into Harvard but it's very easy to
graduate it's much harder to get in than
it is to graduate you have to have
decent test scores at least for now you
have or or you have to be reasonably
accomplished in school and be able to
check a bunch of politically correct
intersectional identity
boxes uh but once you're in you're in I
was once told by my alumni interviewer
for college that it would take an act of
violence for me to get thrown out of
school the grade inflation is so rampant
because it doesn't really matter what
these kids learn the purpose of the
schools right now is a credentialing
institution and a finishing school to
channel you into to Consulting Law
School uh Finance Investment Banking
these sorts of to Washington DC the
state department the Deep State that's
what it's for it's a finishing school
for the the wouldbe political Elite but
our political Elite as we all know they
don't really know much of anything at
all these days and they don't they don't
have to they don't in fact it's it's
better for the ideologues if they don't
really know very much of anything
because when you know things when you
have a proper education then you can
think for yourself and you can see
through shallow
ideologies so what do they do they got
to fill their time the kids have to take
some classes in these schools so what do
they learn they go and they sit and they
listen to Taylor Swift music and they
all rock back and forth and then they
get their degrees and then they run the
world that's what they do now we need to
shed some light on these problems and
when you want to shed a little light
into your home you're going to need to
think about your windows you're going to
want to check out Renewal by Anderson
right now text nolles to 200 300 for
most homeowners window replacement is
not something they want to do but rather
something that they have to do have you
put off replacing the windows in your
home because it's too expensive then I
have great news you can now get a free
inhome window consultation and a free
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer service possible supported by
the best people in the industry right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality Affordable Windows or
patio doors for Z down zero payments and
zero interest for one year I've heard
unsolicited from a carpenter who I heard
me do a read on Renewal by Anderson he
said hey I just want to let you know
when I go into a lot of homes the homes
that have used Renewal by Anderson I can
always tell right away because they have
the best Windows and I have a cousin
actually who works for the company too
and loves it text nolles canw to 200 300
for your free consultation and save 375
bucks off every window and 750 bucks off
every door these savings will not last
long so be sure to check it out text Nes
kwes to 2300 that is NES kwes to 2300
texting privacy policy in terms and
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrols for recurring automated
text marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to window appointment now.com for full
offer details my favorite comment
yesterday is from Kaylee Anne 1994 lady
Ballers has to be the funniest Sports
comedy since baskball the fact that you
guys got Ted Cruz to make a cameo appear
nearly sent me into shock I cannot wait
to watch and we have many
other great cameos there you know I I
spent much of the
night uh
with all of the stars of this including
Senator Cruz but with all the stars of
this movie everyone was ecstatic about
how this thing turned out we had
hundreds of people in in the movie
theater for the premiere maybe two or
three of us had ever seen the movie
before Jeremy and I don't know maybe one
of us had ever seen the movie before and
universally we were all thrilled with
that we cannot wait to share with you
that will be tomorrow now speaking of
the
universities you're going be shocked to
hear this is breaking news stop the
presses graduate students are
complaining here's why we're PhD
students of course I have an emotional
support animal we're PhD students of
course I'm on prescription anxiety
medication of course I question my
decision to do more school every day I
got a 38 on my last midterm and I don't
even care that much we're PhD students
of course I care more about
disappointing my adviser than my own
parents my entire selfworth is based on
how this next experiment goes I have no
idea what my expected year of graduation
is go we're PhD students of course every
single major life milestone is on hold I
don't know what a 401k is we survive off
of Costco frozen meals we're PhD
students of course I get offended when
people think I'm an undergrad we're PhD
students you will be calling me doctor
when I graduate we're PhD students of
course I spend every day Googling the
jobs that I'll have after graduation
we're PhD students and their salaries
which are looking pretty good compared
to what I'm getting paid right now we're
PhD students I want to get an advanced
degree and then go into Academia and
make zero money of course I use
Wikipedia to teach myself the things
that I need to know to read papers I
have a list of papers that I should read
but I'm never going to we're PhD
students of course I just used a
calculator add 2 plus two we're PhD
students of course we're going to cry in
our advisor's office I have no idea what
I'm doing with my life
okay boy they're they're PhD students
but not comedy they're not they're
studying something else part of this is
a little self-facing right we're PhD
students we need to calculator to say
that 2 plus 2 equals 4 sure some of it I
suspect is real which is when they say
yeah I'm looking at the job market and
I'm not going to make a lot of money and
I don't make any money now and I've got
all this work and I don't get any U
credit for it and some of it's kind of
hard and boring and I don't even want to
read the papers that I signed up for and
it's just kind of a miserable
life which raises the
question why are you PhD
students we do not suffer from a
national shortage of PhD students we
have
plenty we we have so many fake academic
departments now we have such a glut of
PhD students and the the standards have
been so lowered in recent decades we
don't we have plenty and we know that
the job market for professors is
absolutely brutal and a lot of these
people will never get jobs in Academia
so you don't need to do it why do you do
it you become a PhD student and then you
become a scholar because you are one of
the really weird people who wants to
dedicate your life to sitting in a small
room reading books and not making a lot
of money but you care so much about the
great conversation taking place in in
our civilization that you want to and
you believe you can contribute to
[Music]
it very few people can actually do that
and will Thrive doing
that the people who for for whom that is
not the best path are going to be
miserable it's a really really hard life
but no one's making them do it a lot of
people do this because they've been
conditioned for their whole lives to
think that this is all that they can do
and because they think that after they
graduate from college this is an easy
enough next step and some of them want
to be Perpetual students they say I
don't have no idea when I'm going to
graduate and a lot of them are in no
rush whatsoever they'll just keep
deferring uh entering the workforce
they'll keep deferring adult
it gets to a theory that Anton and
Scalia got in trouble for bringing up in
a supreme court opinion once which is
the theory of mismatch we are we are
told
today that everything is for everyone
and everyone is perfectly well prepared
to do every single thing and if you ever
suggest otherwise then you are not
Equitable you are unjust you're probably
a racist and a sexist and a this and a
thatst but it's not not everything is
for everyone not every school is for
everyone
and not only will the admission of
people who are not up to Snuff into
these schools harm the other students
because it'll reduce standards it'll
harm the students who are admitted
because they're not going to do very
well and they're either going to flunk
out and be in debt or they're going to
waste a lot of time or what they're
going to do is they're going to stay in
the schools and the schools are going to
create fake departments to accommodate
them because they can't hack it
in certainly not physics or mathematics
probably not history or English either
so they're going to have some fake
critical studies department and they're
going to get their A's in it and they're
going to graduate not really knowing
anything and because there's no job for
a gender Studies major they're probably
going to go to graduate school because
the only job really for a gender Studies
major is to teach gender studies maybe
you can work in some Dei office or
something like that but in any case
you're likely going to go on to uh
graduate school and then you're going to
be miserable not everything is for every
one now there's a story I really wanted
to get to
today this is an important social issue
it's a crisis and the crisis is that
people you know you get a water bottle
like a plastic water bottle and you
drink it and then maybe you leave a
little bit in it and you put you leave
it somewhere maybe you throw it out well
there's a woman who has gone viral for
saying that this is going to deplete all
the water of the Earth because that
water will never escape and we will all
uh die of thirst I don't have time to
get to this today because I've got to
turn to a very dear friend of mine who
is seeing firsthand the craziness going
on on our campuses he's seeing it
firsthand at Yale University that would
be my friend Rabbi schmi hect and that
will happen in the Memom segmentum of
this show the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code nolles kwes at check out
for two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
a